mr jordan peterson
i don't know if you know who that is
he's a psychologist and intellectual and
author
he suggested to me that i raised the
concern that there is a close working
relationship between pfizer fda and cdc
so we we talked about fda
do you worry that this affects both
positive and negative
uh pfizer's chances of getting drugs
approved the fact that there's people
you know that worked at the fda that now
work at pfizer pfizer fda that there's a
kind of pipeline
does this worry you that it affects your
ability to do great
unbiased work
i have zero doubts that this is not
affecting at all
their ability to be unbiased and
regulate
and in order to for this the system also
reinforces that by creating significant
time barriers if someone moves from an
industry to fda she won't be able to
deal with topics for a period of time
and then for even an enhanced period of
time with topics that are related with
the company he or she may come from
i think these
regulators they are
very very strict
uh rightly so
if anything i feel sometimes that maybe
they should
be
a little bit more open-minded
particularly when it comes to new
technologies
rather than trying to judge
and implement the same framework of
variation of new technologies to all
they are always as regulators in the
conservative side but
always always they are unbiased and they
are trying uh the best and it's not only
one or two people they have processes to
make sure that their self checks and
balances within
the agencies both in cdc and in the fda
difficult decisions they bring external
experts that they should express easy
decisions they are internal experts that
they are debating a lot and if there are
disagreements they elevate them so
i think it's
we are lucky to have
good regulators i think
i agree with what you said before
as with all governmental agencies there
is bureaucracy
and the bureaucracy needs to be
addressed
and by saying bureaucracy is not
relaxing
the
the bar the bar needs to remain high
but uh
being
focusing on what matters rather than
on the on the detail
so you don't you know
i've been reading quite a bit about
history you don't worry about human
nature and corruption that can seep in
you're saying institutionally there's
protections against this i think there
is always
the the fear of corruption particularly
when you speak about public servants
but uh clearly the risk is very
different country by country
and speaking about and agencies by
entrances i think the regulatory
agencies
have a very good track record and
history of the us of europe of
england
of a very very good track record of
integrity
it's uh something i think about so i
grew up in the soviet union and um
i need to perhaps introspect this a
little bit but when i was growing up
ethically there was a sense
that bribery is the only way you can get
stuff done
that that was the system of the time uh
like you get pulled over by a police
officer like obviously you need to bribe
them
i mean it was like the way of life
um and then so coming to this country
was is beautiful to see that the rule of
law has so much power and ultimately the
rule of law
when enacted when
uh when it holds up it gives people
freedom
to do the best work of their lives
but they're still human nature and that
that worries me a lot here and again it
goes back to the perception the
communication
when there's people that have worked at
pfizer
and an fda at the cdc
you know you look at their resume they
have those things on their resume it
worries people
are these great leaders
that we are supposed to see as
authorities
are they playing a game on us
i would say
that uh i recognize what you said about
what happened in uh or what i'm sure
that
what you described in
the country that you're coming from it
was
how you experienced it and i know that
there are other countries that you need
to do these things
to do your job
i don't think is the case
in this country
particularly when it comes to those
agents that you mentioned
i think they have a very
high track record and also i don't think
that there are a lot of people that they
are worried about it or doubt i'm sure
like everywhere there will be a minority
but the vast majority of the americans
the vast majority of the europeans the
vast majority of the brits the vast
majority of the israelis
they trust
what fda or ema or cdc
or mhra
will say
you